we've been able to sort of carve out
this Anisha I think we're doing
something to a bag or to a wallet a belt
that's adding just that right amount of
change to other things that are out
there we make everything on this soil we
source the leather here we're not
dictated by a bunch of shareholders who
are saying cut the cost cut the cost
even just the smallest hardware we think
about that and a lot of our hardware we
have cast you know the old-fashioned way
where you literally are taking wax and
you're carving out of it a lot of these
companies will buy a lot of
off-the-shelf stuff and you know we're
hand casting buckles people that really
gravitate towards what we're doing is
they appreciate the fact that you know
we originators we're pretty proud of
that fact to be able to say that almost
17 years now to be working with my
brother on our terms we're still
learning and we're still sort of
fine-tuning our business our products
and our customer I think you know is
sort of growing with us too and they
keep coming back which is fantastic